ce matin régnait un parfum d'excitation
à la British School of Paris
dans quelques heures les élèves de cet
établissement installés à
Croissy-sur-Seine vont vivre un instant
unique avoir la possibilité d'approcher
le roi Charles III en visite en France
ils étaient une cinquantaine à prendre
le départ des Yvelines vers 11h30
direction la capitale je pense qu'on a
vraiment hâte parce qu'on va vraiment
voir
l'Alliance française anglaise et
une belle représentation de nos deux
pays qui soient amis et
toute l'histoire qui a derrière
on ne sait pas si on va pouvoir le
rencontrer mon espère vraiment le voir
et échanger avec nous on espère qu'en
voyant les enfants tous en uniforme il
viendra peut-être nous voir avec la
reine Kamiya les élèves ont assisté cet
après-midi à la cérémonie de ravivage de
la Flamme et de dépôt de gerbe sur la
tombe du soldat inconnu sous l'Arc de
Triomphe ils étaient également aux
premières loges pour le défilé du roi
Charles III et de la reine Kamila sur
les Champs-Élysées après un entretien au
Palais de l'Elysée avec Emmanuel Macron
la journée du monarque anglais s'achève
ce soir dans les Yvelines un dîner
d’état sera donné dans la galerie des
Glaces du château de Versailles avec un
menu Royal servi pour l'occasion en
entrée du homard bleu et tourteau de
cazières réalisé par les chefs
Anne-Sophie Pic le plat principal de la
volaille de Brest signé Yannick aléno
pour poursuivre des fromages français et
anglais enfin en dessert lis pas en haut
de Pierre Hermé un macaron avec sa crème
parfumée à la rose agrémentée de
framboises fraîches et de litchi puis de
150 invités prend en place à table parmi
lesquels Mick Jagger Charlotte
Gainsbourg ou encore Hugh gran